pretend for a moment you are criminal
carrying around a really big bag of
money we've made from all your nefarious
deeds so big that's simply depositing
the cash in your bank we'll get you a
visit from shadowy men in dark
sunglasses you need a plan a way to keep
the cash but get rid of all those
traceable bills here are the two most
common routes criminals use the first
digit people needing to hide large
amounts of money often start by setting
up an offshore company in which
department cash their company's online
they can start one up and mix all that's
needed is a passport number and a credit
a few clicks of a mouse later
gyms from here money can be wired to the
new company's bank account in smaller
amounts keep in mind the pegs flag any
wider choice for over ten small deposits
then fly under the radar looking like
legitimately the fake company can even
pick ups and its owner can drop cleanly
funds course criminals can also go
analogue to them it's as simple as
gathering a bunch of no-good friends in
Las Vegas handing them stacks of cash
and directing them to the tables that's
because unlike betting on horse races
for playing the slot machines casinos
are not required to issue tax bonds for
raising people games regardless of the
amount a few small bets later and the
chips are cash back in and voila new
clean bills just be aware that like
Uncle Sam
is likely to catch someone the only
surefire way to avoid the taxman
vacation never sees the inside of the
back it goes the mattress which let's
face it is a lot more inconspicuous than
a really big back